les restes de l'usine constituent
un ensemble compliqué et difficile à
déchiffrer en raison des nombreuses modifications
apportées au fil du temps à côté de la cheminée de section carrée
ce sont trois bâtiments principaux
où se déroulaient les grandes étapes de production
broyant les grottes traitant les
juifs extraits par la cuisson jusqu'à
cristallisation collectant le
filet noir dans l'égout les bassins cultivés en ligne de rupture
situés dans la partie est de
l'usine permettaient d'alimenter
en eau les moulins de stimulation les bassins
peu profonds situés en auto délimités par des
règles basses permettaient à l'eau produite par le
générateur de refroidir le  l'ensemble de l'
exposition du bâtiment moellons et pierres
maçonnerie la brique est utilisée pour entourer la base
ou les potions susceptibles de mettre le feu la
maçonnerie est généralement enduite de
mortier de chaux et parfois blanchie à la chaux avec du
basaltique envoyer leur matériau est
généralement réutilisé les pierres taillées sont
mélangées avec des murs de galets
des cassures résistantes aux chocs ou même des pièces mécaniques utilisées
pour le remplissage
[Musique]